ونحييكم من جديد تحالف المعارضه السداسي
في تركيا المعروف باسم الطاوله السداسيه
يتفق على رسم زعيمي حزب الشعب الجمهوري
كمال كليتش ليكون مرشحه رئاسيا ينافس
الرئيس رجب تايبردوغان في الانتخابات
المقرره في مايو المقبل الاتفاق جاء عقب
اجتماعا لتحالف المعارضه استمر لاكثر من
اربعه ساعات بعد ان بقي اسم المرشح محله
تباين خلال الاشهر الاخيره ولكن وبعد ان
تم اعلانه تفاهم مشترك على اسم المرشح
تحديدا الخميس الماضي اعترضت رئيسه ثاني
اكبر حزب تركي معارض ميرال على ترشح كريتش
معلنه مطلبها بترشيح احد اسمين الاول
لعمله اسطنبول الاطرم اوغلو وثاني عمده
انقره منصور يافاش وبقي موقف اكشنار
المذكور محطه تساؤلات الى ان قاده لقائها
الاثنين الماضي بعمدتي القرا واسطنبول
منصوريه واكرم امام اوغلو الى انها
اعتراضها امام اوغلوه
في اعقاب الفوز وهو ما تم اتفاق تحالف
المعارضه بشانه وفق الاعلام المحلي على
امل المحاوله بسد الفجوه فجوه الانتخابات
المقرره في مايو المقبله
ميرال اكشنار الملقبه بالمراه الحديديه
سياسيه ومحاميه واكاديميه تركيه بارزه
ولدت في الثامن من يوليو عام
1956 في اسطنبول
[موسيقى]
تقارير اعلاميه تقول انها معروفه
بانتقادها للفساد وانتهاكات حقوق الانسان
في تركيا
عام
1996 تولت منصب وزيره الداخليه
شاركت في تاسيس حزب العداله والتنميه
الحاكمه انسحبت من الحزب ووصفته بالامتداد
لحزب الرفاهه الاسلامي بزعامه نجم الدين
اربكان انضمت الى حزب الحركه القوميه
لاحقا
2016 انسحبت من حزب الحركه القوميه
لمعارضتها لنهج الزعيم الحزب دوله بهتشلي
في تاييد اردوغان
عام 2017 حزب الجيد برئاستها يبصر النور
عام 2018 اول امراه تترشح الانتخابات
رئاسيه في تركيا
نناقش هذا الملف مع ضيوفنا من اسطنبول
الدكتور سمير صالحه في العلاقات الدوليه
اهلا بك ومن اسطنبول دائما زاهد رئيس
وتحرير تركيا اهلا بكم ضيوفي
اسمح لي ان ابدا مع الدكتور سمير صالحه
دكتور سمير هناك شعور بالداخل التركي كما
في خارج تركيا ممن مهتم بشؤون تركيا هناك
شعور وكانه هناك صعوبه في ايجاد منافس
لاردوغان حتى المعارضه لم تتفق على اسم
واحد ولم تدعم اسم واحد الى نهايه المسار
ما السبب
صحيح مساء الخير للجميع اولا يعني طبعا
الاهتمام بالملف التركي موضوع الانتخابات
تحديدا سيتزايد في الاسابيع المقبله اكثر
فاكثر لماذا لانه هذه الانتخابات التي
ننتظرها في 14 ايار مايو المقبل برايه هي
الانتخابات الاول الاولى من نوعها في
تاريخ السياسي الحديث لتركيا حزب العداله
والتنميه في السلطه منذ عقدين والان في
قوى في المعارضه استحالف باتجاه التغيير
بالنسبه للسؤال الذي طرحته نعم يعني الان
ربما قد تكون الامور هدات داخل صفوف
قيادات المعارضه التركيه لكن كل
الاحتمالات وارده يعني المسائل لم تحسم في
عنا اكثر من سبب ودافع يقودنا الى هذا
الاستنتاج نعم مراكشنير
عادت الى الطاوله لكن في كل لحظه هي جاهزه
لتفجير الوضع مجددا اذا ما وجدت انه في
حسابات او مسار سياسي يتعارض مع مصالح
الحزب نفوذ الحزب وسياسات حزب مراد اكشن
حزب الجيد او حزب ايه عنا ازمه مرتقبه في
تشكيل لوائح لوائح المرشحين في صفوف
المعارضه وهذه ازمه لا اعرف كيف ستحسن من
الاخشانير اليوم قالت انها لن تدخل في اي
تحالف حزبي انتخابي مع اي حزب فتاخد
الانتخابات بمفردها بحسبها وهذا يعني انه
كل الان البقيه الاحزاب في المعارضه
ستلتحق بحزب كمال حزب الشعب الجمهوري كيف
يرضي هذه الاحزاب الصغيره يعني في اكثر من
ماده لا اريد ان ادخل في كل التفاصيل فقط
لاقول لك باستنتاج انه الام ور لم تحسن
بعد لانه ذهبنا نحو التهدئه في بين
الاحزاب داخل المعادن استاذ هل تتوافق مع
ضيفي على ان الامور لم تحسب لم تحسم بعد
واضيف كذلك ما قراناه حتى في تعليقات
الاتراك على هذا الموضوع يقال بانه هذا
التخبط داخل المعارضه يمثل او قد يمثل اول
خطوه فشل في محاوله ازاحه اردوغان
يعني اعتقد الحديث عن النجاح والفشل مبكر
حتى هذه اللحظه
لاننا نتحدث عن شيء يحصل في تاريخ السياسه
التركيه بهذه الصيغه للمره الاولى يعني
ابتداء يجب ان نعلم ان احزاب المعارضه
السياسيه هي احزاب ابتداء متباينه سياسيا
وايديولوجيا وفكريا
وهوياتيا الى حد ما وبالتالي
التباين فيما بينها امر طبيعي في رايي
الشخصي وخاصه اننا نتحدث عن يمين ويسار
ونتحدث عن اقصى اليمين وربما اقصى اليسار
في نفس الوقت وبالتالي الذي جمع هذه
الاحزاب السياسيه ابتداء شيئين اثنين
الشيء الاول الفشل الذي منوا به او يعني
تكبدوا خلال ربما خمسه عشر عاما ماضيه في
ظل حكومات متلاحقه للعداله والتنميه الامر
الاخر الشيء الذي فرض عليهم الت الاوقات
والتحالفات هو النظام الرئاسي الذي
استحدث بعد عام 2016 هذا النظام فرض نظام
التحالفات بشكل قانوني وبشكل دستوري وبشكل
الزمهم لان يتحالفوا وبالتالي نحن شهدنا
مبادرات تحالف في بدايه الامر منذ عام
2019 في انتخابين في الانتخابات
البرلمانيه عندما كان هناك بعض القوائم
المشتركه بين الحزب الجيد وحزب الشعب
الجمهوري هذا التحالف ادى في نتيجه المطاف
الى ان يفقد الحزب الحاكم حزب العداله
والتنميه للمره الاولى الاغلبيه
البرلمانيه واضطر للتحالف مع الحركه
القوميه هذا التحالف ابتداء وانتهاء
استطاع الفوز في بلديات كبرى بعد ربع قرن
في بلديه اسطنبول وانقره وعدد كبير من
البلديات الاخرى من المؤكد اليوم التحالف
لم يعد بين حزبين نتحدث عن توسع كبير حصل
في هذا التحالف ومع تباين ايضا في الرؤى
السياسيه وكذلك ايضا
المحا صالح ربما الحزبيه في هذا الصدد
ايضا موجوده لكن من المؤكد انهم اتفقوا
على النقطه الاولى الاساسيه المهمه وهو
المرشح الرئاسي وصيغه النظام الرئاسي
وخارطه الطريق بعد 14 جلسه استمرت عام
اكثر من عام كامل وبالتالي ما حصل انا
اعتقد هو امر يحصل في تاريخ السياسه
التركيه منذ تاسيس الجمهوريه وحتى للغه
الاولى في اطار نحن نتحدث عن سيد فقط
حضرتك لانك تقول بان المعارضه تمكنت يعني
اعتبرت بان هناك ايجابيه في الموضوع بتمكن
المعارضه من اقتراح اسمه لكن حتى هذا
الاسم يقول البعض بانه ليس بتلك الشعبيه
طبعا انقل لحضرتك ما يقوله مراقبون اتراك
وسياسيون حتى في داخل التركي وحضرتك اكيد
تعلم ذلك خليني انقل فقط الى ضيفي الدكتور
سمير ان كان يوافقك او يختلف معك حول هذه
النقطه دكتور سمير هل مجرد اقتراح اسمه هو
نقطه ايجابيه او ان هذا الاسم يجب ان يكون
اقتراحه اقتراح جدي ويجب ان ينافس كذلك
اردوغان
يعني انا اتفق معك في الجزء الثاني من
السؤال علينا ان نرى يعني الاسم لا يكفي
نعم قد تكون خطوه مهمه توافق حول اسم جمال
كلش لكن علينا ان نرى الان الترجمه
العمليه لما سيفعله
حمايه هذه التحالفات تحت سقف احزاب
المعارضه ما الذي سيفعله الان قبل قبل كل
شيء في عنا مساله علينا ان يعني نحسمها
انه نسب الاصوات في الحكم والمعارضه
متقاربه جدا يعني اربعين خمسه واربعين لكل
كتله اذا كل طرف الان سيحاول ان يبحث عن
شريك يعطيه فرصه الحصول وتجاوز نصف
الاصوات يعني 50 زائد واحد
الان الكثير من استبعاد الرايه تقول انه
الكفه تميل لصالح عذاب المعارضه لماذا
لانه حزب الشعوب حزب الشعب حزب الشعوب
الديمقراطي المحسوب على صوت الكردي في
جنوب شرق تركيا قال انه رحب باختيار كمان
وقال انه لن يعلن مرشح منافس في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه هذا يعني نقطه
ايجابيه لصالح احزاب المعارضه ان تحصل على
دعم حزب الشعوب الديمقراطيه حزب الشعوب
الديمقراطيه عنده حوالي تسعه او عشره
بالمئه من مجموع الاصوات وهذه تكون كافيه
لتلعب دور بيضه القبان في الحسم النتائج
ما الذي سيجي هذه نقطه اولى نقطه ثانيه
باختصار لن اطيل اعود الى السؤال الذي
طرحته الان كل هذا الحوار سيكون مرتبط
ايضا بعمليه ارضاء الاحزاب السياسيه في
المعارضه
ارضاء الاحزاب الصغيره من قبل حزب الشعبي
الجمهوري يعني ربما اغضاب
الكوادر الاساسيه في حزب الشعب عندما ياخذ
الاشخاص من الخارج ويضمهم الى حزبه
ويعطيهم نسب معينه تحت سقف البرلمان هذا
سيخلق اهتزازات حزبيه في حزب الشعب
الجمهوري نفسه كيف سيتعامل مع ذلك هذه
مساله براي في غايه الصعوبه طيب استاذ
زاهر يبقى السؤال الى اي مدى يمكن ان
نتحدث عن متانه هذه المعارضه واحتفاظها
وتمسكها بهذا الاسم البعض يقول بانه
السيده ميرال اكشنات قاد قادره ان لحساب
او لاخر ان تغير المعادله
نعم ربما نظريا هذا الكلام صحيح لكن
المعارضه جميعها وخاصه قياداتها التاريخيه
سواء كمالكلشتار اوغلو او مره الاكشنر او
غيرهم من القيادات السياسيه الموجوده الان
في المعارضه هي تخوض معركه البقاء في
الحياه السياسيه ولا تخوضوا بالضروره
معركه ضد اردوغان وبالتالي امامهم فقط
احتماليه النصر لانني اعتقد انه لن تكون
هناك اي حياه سياسيه لاي هذه لاي من رؤساء
هذه الاحزاب السياسيه الموجوده الان اذا
لم تستطع الفوز ولم تحقق النصر الذي مطلوب
منها في هذه الانتخابات وبالتالي
كمالكوليسترول لن يبقى
لن يبقى رئيسا لحزب الشعب الجمهوري ولا
السيده مر سيتلاشى ربما ليس فقط بل حزبها
ايضا سيتلاشى ان لم يستطيعوا التوافق في
بينهم والوصول الى النجاح فالمساله
بالنسبه لهم حياتيه وبالتالي انا في رايي
الشخصي من الحكمه السياسيه ومن الواقعيه
السياسيه انهم سيتوافقون بما يضمن مصلحتهم
ابتداء لا اقول مصلحه تركيا وبالتالي
مصلحتهم في الفوز وسيفعلون كل ما بوسعهم
من اجل الوصول الى الفوز لا في اطار
التنازلات التي سيقدمونها لبعضهم البعض
وبالتالي الوصول لنتيجه المرجوه منهم
وبالتالي الوصول الى ربما خلافات سياسيه
لاحقا سنتحدث عنها بعد الفوز
وامامنا سبعين يوما يعني في الفوز ومن
بعدها يمكن ان نتحدث عن هذه التجذبات
لننتظر ونرى شكرا جزيلا لكما من اسطنبول
رئيس تحرير تركيا والدكتور سمير صالحه
الاستاذ في العلاقات الدوليه شكرا لكما
[موسيقى]
نتوقف مع فاصل من بعده سنعود لنتابع
كتاب طموحات الخفيه لمدير المعهد الفرنسي
للدراسات الدوليه يتحدث عن سعي ايران
لضمان امنها بالحصول على السلاح النووي